which has already been done the
so-called mini budget a week and a half
ago crashed the market and has resulted
in not just higher borrowing costs for
government but also higher mortgage
rates for everybody else people are
incredibly worried as they come to the
end of fixed-rate mortgage deals or if
they're trying to get on the housing
ladder for the first time of how they're
going to afford it and that is the
responsibility and it's down to the mini
budget from the Prime Minister and the
chancellor so so much damage has already
been done do you give them any marks for
showing that they can adapt
well the mini budget showed what their
instincts were their instincts were to
cut taxes for the wealthiest in society
paid for by borrowing which in the end
current and future taxpayers will have
to pay for it was obvious they weren't
going to get this through the House of
Commons they were forced into this
screeching U-turn but so much damage has
already been done with higher government
borrowing costs and huge worries for
people about how they're going to afford
their mortgages
do you think this will do anything to
calm the Rockets
well we haven't seen anything like that
so far borrowing costs for government
borrowing costs of people with mortgages
remain at incredibly high levels they
leaped when the chancellor made his
statement to Parliament they increased
again the following Monday when he
doubled down on it and as I say for
people who are coming to the end of
fixed her mortgage deals funded they're
now going to be paid hundreds of pounds
more a month and for those people who
are trying to get onto the housing
ladder but then found that mortgage
products have been withdrawn the damage
was done when the chancellor got up and
made a fiscal statement without any type
of independent forecast with huge
amounts of borrowing to pay for tax cuts
for those who are already wealthy do you
think they'll be able to hold the line
now of not having an obr forecast until
the end of November I wrote to the
chancellor yesterday and said that when
the obr give the Prime Minister and the
chancellor their forecast this Friday
that that should be available to
everybody else as well we should have
got the obr forecast when the chancellor
delivered his fiscal statement one of
the reasons why the markets then became
so volatile was because that failure to
produce a forecast along with the
sacking of the permanent secretary at
the treasury along with the undermining
of the bank of England all of these
things undermine confidence that
investors who saw Britain as a safe
place a reliable place to invest the
Prime Minister and the chancellor are
doing so much damage to our country's
reputation and what the Prime Minister
and the chancellor is saying on that is
that the full obr forecast won't be
ready until that point there we all have
said that they had a forecast ready for
when the chancellor did his fiscal
statement a week and a half ago we can't
afford to wait until the 23rd of
November which is what the Prime
Minister and Chancellor currently say
when the obr present their forecast this
Friday to the Prime Minister and the
chancellor that should also be presented
to Parliament and should be presented to
the British people it is a ROM that the
chancellor did a fiscal statement
without any sort of independent forecast
we need that forecast to understand the
scale of the government borrowing the
impact on the government finances and
the impact on inflation and economic
growth too
do you think they'll have to end up also
operating Universal Credit in line with
inflation well the idea that the
government can afford to give tax cuts
to the wealthiest but not upright
benefits in line with inflation I think
is grotesque and there are many people
who are saying that the government need
to rethink this one as well the Prime
Minister yesterday refused to say
whether people who with disabilities
people on Universal Credit will see
their benefits go up in line with
inflation uh next year that uncertainty
for people who are already seeing huge
increases in their energy prices in the
weekly food shop it's a time of huge
anxiety and yet the government seem to
think that cutting taxes for people who
are already on big salaries or
businesses are already making big
profits that seems to be their priority
this idea of trickle-down Economics
which has failed in the past and will
fail again because haven't don't just
need to reverse the budget they need to
rethink their whole idea of trickle-down
Economics which is causing huge anxiety
and has sent the markets into a panic
because said that his approach is to
stay calm
do you think there is a way now there is
a route if if they announce the supply
side reforms if they publish the obr
forecast that they can start to turn
things around
well all of the volatility and the
crashing of financial markets was
because of a fiscal statement that
didn't apply any of the normal rules
there should have been an independent
forecast along with that and that lack
of a forecast after undermining the bank
of England after sacking the respected
permanent Secretary of the Treasury gave
out a signal that Britain was no longer
a safe place to invest and that's why
the chancellor needs to publish that
independent offers the budget
responsibility forecast so that we can
all assess the impact of the tax and
spending measures announced in the
fiscal statement a week and a half ago
there really is no time to waste we've
already seen because of the chancellor
and the Prime Minister a big spike in
borrowing costs of people with mortgages
and for businesses with business loans
the government now need to get a grip
they should reverse their budget recall
Parliament to do so and rethink their
whole approach which is doing such
damage to ordinary working people and
businesses across our country